like no big surprise here we had already
had indications that yes Samsung were
going to say that the batteries were the
key issue behind the overheating note 7
smartphones and some of them actually
going on to actually catch fire and
create a hazard for consumers so we've
heard from something electronics now
saying in a statement that 40 batteries
did trigger the note 7 fires and saying
that they're going to strengthen battery
safety the head of the mobile division
for samsung apologized over the note 7
issue and all such we've got some
pictures coming these live images of
actually the company itself making this
announcement saying you know telling us
all about what did trigger these fires
off here yes and hopefully we're going
to get a lot more details about the
exact issue that may have been behind
the faulty batteries now last year there
was a u.s. consumer safety agency which
had said that the problem was that
batteries made by samsung SDI were
slightly too big and pinched when
inserted in the phone which had caused
the phones to overheat now we're
probably going to find out a lot more
today from this investigation exactly as
to what if that was the reason behind it
and exactly you know what the issues
were in the batteries critics at the
time said that part of the issue was
that something had rushed to get its
note servant out before Apple made its
product lawned at the end of last year
so that may have contributed to perhaps
the problems with the batteries all
right well I mean it does though
surprisingly seem that the overall
Samson business is holding up pretty
well but well yes because Samsung does a
lot more than make consumer electronics
of course this is what its best-known
forth to many people but it has a very
successful and in fact very strong at
the moment chip division that's doing
very well and that's driven by demand
for smartphones especially by Chinese
handset makers as well so that's doing
particularly well it had its
fourth-quarter earnings guidance earlier
in january where we saw that it's go
posting it's a biggest operating profits
in three years in the last quarter at
seven point eight billion dollars which
of course beat analyst estimates and
that's despite the issues with this
samsung note 7 phone and the best
performer many analysts think will be
the chip division on the back of
stronger prices we're actually going to
have a lot more details out in its
fourth-quarter earnings release which is
out in fact
morrow 24th of January so we will see a
bit more in terms of how the divisions
broke down and what divisions how they
performed but of course consumer
electronics probably not performing as
well as some of the others for samsung
electronics actually you know those live
images we just came had coming from
Seoul was actually the head of product
there and he's just apparently just
apologized for this whole well I guess
crisis if you will so of course we're
monitoring any further headlines as and
when we do get them